going back to like languages and stuff
though like i did have this thought
and
don't mean to like sound elitist or
keep something else right but i just
like talking [ __ ]
do you think you can truly understand a
culture if you don't have
if you don't like have at least like a
bit of an understanding of the language
because what made me think this was
learning japanese has really made me
appreciate thai and thai culture and
made me think about
my own language or my second language in
a way that i never thought about before
right yeah because to me learning a
language or like learning thai was just
the way i communicated to my mom and i
didn't like it didn't like i didn't
internalize just how much of my culture
was steeped into my language until i
started to try learning japanese right
and you know like like we just said you
can translate things right you can
translate ideas but one thing one thing
that i've found learning japanese or
like now appreciating time or is like
sometimes you can't sometimes it's
really hard to translate a certain
feeling you get from a phrase
i think it's impossible to learn a
language without learning the culture
and vice versa i think you can learn the
language without knowing anything about
the culture really yeah i don't think
you can i think you can but
i mean what's the point yeah
but but you can't but like i i think
yeah of course you can because it's you
know it's it's a set of rules and you
follow them and you say the words like
right but just because you know
but like i would like like you can teach
a robot a language doesn't have to
understand the culture behind it but no
that's a robot right what i'm saying is
that like well if that can be done right
that shows that i mean you don't need to
understand the culture like yeah you
don't have to understand the culture but
i think if you want to
on the other hand if you want to
understand more about the culture no
your question was knowing the culture
right yeah yeah like i think if you want
to know more about the culture the
language is probably the best way to do
it yeah uh you know yeah but i would
argue that they kind of they go hand in
hand right like i feel because the
language of a country is a culture
so it's like i feel like yes you could
like you know as you said you can teach
a robot japanese right yeah and it can
you know speak back in japanese but
that's because that's a robo right there
it has no understanding of the actual
language and i feel in you can only get
so far
learning a language without knowing the
culture yeah yeah and only like
counterpoint to that it's like well on
the other hand it's like english is
constantly changing yeah as as our most
likely yeah right like you go back 80
years and you watch japanese you
probably understand the japanese that
well right it's the same thing you know
language is a constantly changing thing
yeah but languages are like culture as a
whole but in some ways culture is a
reflection of the language that changes
over time so that's that's that's
exactly my point right where it's it's
it's it's been like such a weird journey
for me learning japanese and just having
like i i feel like having like a
different part of my mind unlocks i
don't i don't it's it's like it's so i
think it's limitless it's it's so weird
to just use one percent of his brain
yeah it's so weird to try to describe
this to someone who has like never tried
to learn a language or has or only knows
one language yeah you kind of like even
you kind of even like
think differently with a second language
or like you know it's uh well people
told me people have told me i sound
different when i speak japanese yeah
like i become a totally different person
but i'm like i would argue that that's
because
the japanese side of me that's speaking
japanese follows more of the japanese
cultural way of life
which is completely different to the
australian way like is there any like
japanese concepts in language that you
think
are like
have can't be translated or like are
difficult to translate
oh absolutely i mean like
yeah yeah i mean you know it's i don't
think it's just like it's not just like
one
you know phrase that can't be translated
or whatever i mean there's lots of yeah
you know
i would argue that there's a lot of
english words that can't be translated
oh that's definitely um but
yeah like boss influences right or you
know there's a lot of japanese words
that take an entire sentence to describe
in english yeah yeah right but like you
know there are some like especially like
you know i think the whole thing of like
just kanji especially is so difficult to
translate without fully first explaining
what the [ __ ] kanji even is right yeah
and i that's why i always found it
interesting that there are so many like
japanese like you know manga anime and
stuff like that that so heavily rely on
the japanese
language and therefore the japanese
culture yeah that
have somehow been translated and have
somehow still been understood by people
who have no knowledge of the language or
the culture yeah like it still baffles
my mind how popular the monogatari
series is outside of japan because that
show
i've seen the subtitles a lot of it gets
lost in translation so hard yeah but
somehow people still enjoy it the ideas
are still there maybe i don't know but i
feel that like
you know it's it's interesting to see
like how a japanese person would react
to a show like that this is how a
non-japanese person would react to a
show both good both positive outcome
yeah but a completely different level of
understanding of what makes it good you
know and like the language also tells
the history of the country yeah yeah
well you know like you know we have a
lot of french words in english that yeah
from you know when friends had control
over england japanese has tons of
english words and you know also japanese
have a lot of words that are like very
cute sounding to reflect the nature of
japanese society right now you know it
all it all kind of reflects it in a way
that's really interesting and
kind of bizarre really it doesn't really
make much sense sometimes because
because i i realized when i went back to
england and i was speaking you know
speaking thai again to my mum that there
were just like some thai concepts and
thai like words that i just didn't know
couldn't be translated into english
until i thought about it like there's
this there's this concept of in thai
called jai which means the heart right
and a lot of things
a lot of things revolve around this
concept of jai so basically jai lan
means hot heart so that means you're
impatient right and that's that's the
literal translation right
yen means patience cold heart right
now there's this word called nam jae
which means water flowing from the heart
okay and you explain that to english
you're like what the [ __ ] is that
absolutely water water flowing from a
heart disease
and it's it's like it's incoming yeah
water flowing from the heart means
it's it's someone's it's someone giving
genuine acts of kindness with no strings
attached they just want to be welcoming
and they are willing to give just these
genuine acts of kindness so that
everyone around them has a good time and
is more welcomed
and they do that with no strings
attached and like i'd like there there
is no english translation for that like
because the closest thing you can say is
many words to explain it yeah exactly
the closest thing you can say is like
kinds but it's not it's not really kind
but like unless you know
tai i mean not unless you know thai but
like if you've been to thailand you can
feel this feeling right this feeling
that exudes from the country which is
why which which is why it's a great
place to go on holiday because everyone
in there is so welcoming because
a lot of people there have nam chai
and like it's it's so hard to explain
that into a different language because
in thai that is just a concept that you
feel because it's just so steeped in the
culture yeah and you feel it when you go
there but if you don't speak the
language then you don't have a proper
word to place on this feeling that you
feel people exuding same thing with
japan as well you feel a certain feeling
from you know that you know
someone who grew up in japan may have a
different way of thinking and a
different way of acting than say someone
who grew up outside of japan and there's
there's so many like
nuances with just culture and just
psychology that is so like steeped into
language that it's it's you can explain
it but it's from what i've from what
i've
from what i've experienced is the
difference between
explaining a joke and understanding a
joke you know yeah now now that i've
been you know an avid anime watch of my
entire life and i've had japanese
concepts explained to me it's like been
so weird actually
feeling some of these concepts as
opposed to just understanding them and i
guess yeah like one concept i can think
of in japanese is like this idea of
reading the room or reading this yeah oh
yeah yeah it's all kooky yeah or like
air in japanese but like and you know we
say like when we read the room we say
kooky or which means to read the read
the air yeah but like it's not quite the
same as when you say reading the app or
reading the room in english yeah there's
like a whole other like it's it's like a
socio-psychological element to it that
it's like it's so important to read the
room and not reading the room or not
reading the air in japanese culture is
so like
not good like that's like you're
basically just you know societally just
it's a societal death basically yeah
because it's it's like a communication
within japanese society that doesn't
require words yeah it's a thing that
doesn't require words and it's like this
like non-spoken
social etiquette of sorts yeah that
japanese people have just hardwired into
their brain from a young age because
it's just so integrated into society and
you know
again that's like another concept where
you can explain it in another language
and i'm sure you know if you like looked
into it and understood it then you know
you'd be like all right i get what that
means you know i can i know how to say
it in this context but
you know even for me
it's like i don't think i could fully
use or utilize the word or fully
understand what that word means because
i personally didn't grow up as heavily
in an environment like that yeah like i
grew up with it sure but i wasn't born
and raised in germany yeah so it's like
there's that sort of disconnect of
yeah as you said like understanding it
from an explanation and just
understanding it through osmosis yeah
and like
yeah it's it's i'm sure there's like
there's a lot of things that i've never
thought about in english as well that
maybe maybe it's just like purely unique
to
our culture in our language and it's
just like i don't know it was it's it's
just been it's just been really weird
it's made me think about things i've
always took for granted my life where
like language was just me conveying an
idea and i just didn't realize that me
speaking english meant that i was
learning a part of the history that our
country has been through you know
that's just it's it runs way deeper than
i gave it any credit for
man discovers language
is history in disguise
i can see why people get into like
linguistics no i i didn't get it either
at first and i'm just like they were
literally just talking about linguistics
yeah yeah
like for the longest time i'm like wait
so what do you study linguistics yeah
the [ __ ] is that i'm like do you know
how to speak what do you need to know
what do you need to know you already
know you already know the language
what more is there to learn about it but
now i understand i'm like it runs so
much deeper than just i know a lot of
words you know yeah it makes me in some
ways because i you know i'm i'm fluent
in welsh and obviously i lived there all
my uh young adult life i guess oh yeah
no child life before adults yeah and uh
you know in some ways i'm like yeah i
think i'm i know the culture of course i
know the culture i'm like wait wait wait
what what exactly is it again i'm like
like sometimes i think oh man it's kind
of hard to define it it's kind of hard
to explain anything in some ways i'm
just like yeah it's like the uk but like
way more friendly like that's just kind
of it like that's the culture like yeah
very similar but friendly i guess and
and more focused on being expressive
it's not until you look at it through
like a third person which is almost why
i feel like sometimes dare i say it's
like it's almost easier to
to look at a culture and it's totality
when you're not a part of it yeah yeah
because you can kind of like disconnect
your disconnect your experiences from it
yeah and sometimes welsh i'm like
someone's like explain welsh culture to
me i'm like
[Music]
yeah that's what's so hard it's like is
it actually part of that country's
culture or is it just your experience of
living through that culture right right
that's what i i don't you know and
obviously some of my experience is
totally different to someone else and so
that would it would have been culture
would be totally different would it be
easier to describe welsh culture if the
other person spoke welsh do you think
it would probably be a good way to kind
of hash things out be like
what do you think about this
would you say this is
yeah like it's one of those things where
it's like i you know
getting a cultural um you know hearing
if i explain welsh culture to you it
could be totally different to how
someone else
might explain it to you yeah i feel
we've experienced that quite a few times
on this podcast where we'd say something
yeah well oh yeah yeah all australians
like this and then
no it's not the only difference is
there's not enough welsh people to
fact-check me
sorry the one welsh trash taste fan is
like um
like every time person is just happy to
like be recognized so it's just like
okay
they're
but it's always been fascinating
whenever i've like experienced my
perspective of like australian culture
or japanese culture and there have been
people on the other side watching our
show being like no that's just you
and it kind of opens my up being like oh
yeah maybe it is just me
it's so weird